hello friends and welcome to the lobby
games what's weekly hang it every
tuesday 2 p.m. pacific right here on
gamespot com or on twitch.tv for such
gamespot or in your podcast application
of choice if you are listening to this
in your podcast you can't see my sweet
green shirt with you Peter copied it's
true you dirty son of a bee it's my own
tint of sweet green it is a delicious
sweet green as an Irishman I really
appreciate it Scott other words i'm
sorry i didn't get the memo yeah you're
gonna blew it full monochromatic mr.
fred perry yeah well you know you got to
do it maybe that's the next time maybe
that's evocative of the video games
you've been playing I'm feeling bright
and cheerful cuz i play completed
uncharted last night which I talk about
later you feel bright and cheerful
because dooms a good video game yeah
maybe yeah we're gonna talk about home
front in a second yeah not isn't
cheerful not as cheerful no well we've
got a bunch of great stuff to talk about
this week I'm chardon doom like I
already said we're also going to talk
about the sort of the the myth or myth
or maybe not myth around early review
copies like when we get them and is that
like a massive red flag for review
scores cuz i know it doom that sort of
brought up that debate as well i was
going to talk about some of the most
influential mods of all the time because
that's something that sort of popped up
in my head recently with overwatch and
thinking back a bit the old Battlefield
games and stuff and so we're gonna do
that in a second but first of all Scott
Butterworth you have been playing
homefront the revolution game that has
had a colorful development history I
think it's easy to say it's finally out
of debt today yes and we have a review
in progress up on the site full review
of be going live tomorrow Mars cross
yeah what do you think of it just right
off the bat how good is home front it's
not great I mean I've been seeing some
other scores go up and and my score will
likely be in line with those scores if
people have been paying attention it's
been getting a lot of fives and sixes a
few 7s Jim sterling really hated it
right yep which seems kind of
unwarranted and he gave the game a one
and it's it's not a one it's not great
but I'd I managed to have quite a bit of
fun playing the game actually but i had
to overlook a lot of flaws in order to
do it and like yeah there's that game it
just has a lot of problems I think you
go sure let's let's first of all talk
about I guess maybe this is unfair I
mean you can see it in the footage right
now
so you sit next to Peter and Peter was
playing quake 3 which is in glory 60
frames a second and what I sling do so I
do what I say quick threes in collage no
you were not playing quick Jesus this I
just want to do quick you're playing do
when it was like looking super buttery
and speaking of butter Scott Butterworth
next to him at your play you're playing
homefront on it look man it looked super
spotty yes I'm right form a super choppy
also like a you tell me not to make
stupid jokes I don't but I was
accidental I'm so sorry I think I may be
influencing negative way but yeah the
frame weighted frame rate is just one of
several technical problems and yeah
across all three platforms red have now
played the game on all three platforms
it is choppy pretty much throughout
there are moments when it's fine but
there are also moments when it slows
just like a total sputter like late in
the game there are submissions where
there's a bunch of vehicles and a ton of
enemies and all that is enough to make
the game just slowed to a crawl right
crazy but even in just sort of like
regular minute to minute action you know
nothing super crazy even then it's
choppy and unpredictable and so in terms
of performance obviously not great what
what else you sort of alluding to in
relation to technical issues I mean
there are rough edges basically
everywhere you look in this game no
matter what you're playing you're gonna
find something weird like AI enemies
that just stand there instead of
fighting back that's a weird one like
trying to hide from enemies and having
an being spotted through a wall small
moments of like there's a clip in our
review in progress video or you see my
hand clip through a door as i put bit
push it open right that happens
literally every time in that particular
animation on ps4 i notice it doesn't
happen on xbox and pc for whatever
reason they're the best versions to play
it on have they have their own problems
man like in all of them stutter any time
it auto the game of auto saves like it's
again it's worse on ps4 it'll the game
will seriously just freeze for two
seconds as it auto saves and start
eyeing him every time wow yeah it's less
noticeable on xbox and pc but it still
happens and it's like guys this is kind
of not acceptable oh I mean game auto
saves every couple minutes and for the
you know it really kind of pulls you out
of the experience but it just kind of
did everything stops the game literally
freezes that's just a bit much yeah
I was put the word out for some for
questions over Twitter clock working and
asks had his home front open world is
distinguish itself from other FPS open
world games sure yeah so happy to talk
about the structure but to answer that
question directly it kind of doesn't um
I mean had the technical issues not been
present and had there been some
thoughtful editing where they had you
know excluded parts where kind of drags
or excluded mechanics don't work as well
it could have been a really solid game
not a great game not a really like
inspired or groundbreaking game but a
really just fun open-world shooter hmm
but like I said it's not groundbreaking
and those technical issues are there so
the way the game is structured is it's
pretty basic there are eight different
sections each of the sections is open
but you can't kind of walk from one end
to the other like you can in a fallout
game okay so each area exist on its own
and they are relatively large and you
can't explore them freely but you have
to hop between them over the course of
the campaign which directs you through
them I'm sorry if they're almost like
linear sort of like open little smaller
open worlds yeah yeah yeah and they are
all like if you look at the world map
you can kind of see how they're
connected but is it like there are
loading screen something or is it all
it's all set in Philadelphia so it's I
mean which doesn't resemble any part of
Philadelphia that I've ever visited her
scene but okay fine they're like
particular landmarks that are borrowed
is that Bruce Springsteen song playing
over the top constantly I I wish there
were some Bruce Springsteen the sound is
actually one of the weirder parts of the
game we're like there will be music
playing when there's nothing happening
it'll be like just really tense music it
must be like cuddling there's somebody
about to attack me like I don't what why
is this happening and I'm just kind of
like paranoid and it I can't tell if
it's a bug or just a weird design choice
like I said that's like I've been living
my life when you probably had the same
thing over the weekend with doom or
whenever the music is hyped unlike on
edge completely yeah like there's one
more of these [ __ ] around here
somewhere yeah we've we've been
conditioned like that's how games work I
mean it's in movies and everything yeah
it's it's a very subtle like hey like
you should be paying attention
something's going to try to kill you so
it's weird when nothing tries to kill
you and the music implies otherwise what
the hell so what about the sort of
general action is managing that
distinguishes at outside of I mean it's
solid it's fine
shooting mechanics the stealth doesn't
work quite as well so it's really kind
of a shooter stealth game you can
approach it either way but right the
stealth is super inconsistent like there
were times when I was spotted and I
didn't understand why and there were
times when I would see someone's
awareness meter starting to fail and I
would just sprint in the opposite
direction and that was fine for some
reason you think that would cause their
meter to feel faster because this crazy
person is now sprinting in the other
direction but it didn't seem to make a
difference but the shooting is actually
pretty fun it feels a lot like a far cry
game which makes sense given this is a
cry engine games right yeah I mean you
have kind of model weapons you can add
attachments on the flies all that kind
of stuff so that there's nothing
particularly distinctive about it or
really memorable about the
moment-to-moment shooting but it can be
it can be fun it can get really frantic
and chaotic the enemies are not bullet
sponges which is really nice but neither
are you so you kinda have to be careful
and thoughtful and there's actually like
small platforming moments as well where
you have to get to like a transceiver on
top of a building you didn't need to
find your way up there's so certain
moments like that that remind me of like
dying light for example right so that
actually helps to break up the the
gameplay and add some another kind of
dimension so again like I have fun in a
lot of those moments is just that
there's so much other stuff to deal with
and in the meantime then really pulls
the experience down it's a shame yeah I
guess last point on this there is some
sort of co-op stuff going on here as
well how does that play out yeah so
there is a are two completely separate
components in this game there is the
single player campaign which is actually
like remarkably long it's a very
substantial campaign and this is one of
the sort of best attributes of the game
that there is a really long and
substantial in varied campaign it's
probably a good 20 20 hours for most
players if you want to you if you do
everything you can easily extend it to
like 25 if you just rush through you can
probably do it in 15 but it's far more
substantial than the first homefront
game but in addition to that there is a
co-op campaign which is six missions
that are kind of sort of designed to be
replay I'm not quite sure why you would
there's nothing encouraging you to do
that other than the sort of the the
selectable difficulty level but each of
those can be completed in like 10 to 15
minutes so six missions is not a lot and
there's a really basic unlock system but
it's all done through loot crates so you
can't actually pick what you're
unlocking
you just have to hope you get with your
what you want it's it i'm not super
impressed i don't i don't feel like it
really adds much the experience to be
completely honest but again it's a
totally separate component so if you're
interested you think and get something
out of it great go play it if not it's
just kind of there and I don't know ya
know what else is just kind of there
how's that timesplitters 2 yeah that's
that's a real thing there's an easter
egg in the game which they've actually I
guess so this is I think I believe
public knowledge be I actually stumbled
onto this without knowing that yeah
there's one section late in the game
when you're like in a prison and you go
up to one of these like abandoned floors
and you find an old arcade cabinet and
if you approach it it's like hit button
to play like okay and so I did and it
turns out that it's like three levels
from timesplitters loss it hurts it up
yep yeah and it plays the game's opening
cutscene and you can play those missions
and yeah right is this like the what I
without getting into spoilers about
other games this seems to be the new
thing and video games now is that you
just throw another video game inside of
we're at that point where that that's a
thing that goo might sense yeah I think
we're 343 in a week I think the original
didn't the original black ops have like
zork or something like it had no could
have I don't remember there was
something like it's full game hidden
away and I think that was the first time
I remember finding a complete game
within another game I bet it is so been
a complete movie member the darkness had
to kill a mockingbird and I know it did
yeah I didn't know that you know you sit
down with your girlfriend like Jackie
sits down with his girlfriend yeah
hectic illa mockingbirds plays on a
television it's the whole movie well you
can literally watch like added Atticus
Finch chat for like two hours that's
really crazy really weird my favorite
inclusion would be in blades of Steel on
the NES we're between periods I think it
was every period maybe it wasn't
everyone you could plague radius oh
really shooter had to kill the time
until you died you would yeah and that
loading screen patent is now gone so
maybe we'll see more that sort of stuff
with ridge racer and galaxia i think it
was was in that 10 in urging lee we're
seeing fewer tree loading screens there
are plenty in home front unfortunately
but games like you know fall out or
witcher you know basically limited them
so the real shame we're not gonna get
you know too many loading game loading
screen games maybe a max of shame a lot
of the people in the chat were noticing
the little autosave pauses that were
happening in our game plan yeah it
[ __ ] a stroke
every time and what's funny is often the
audio will continue on to sort the game
itself is frozen a stream of sports cats
yeah so I hope that that registers are
people watching our footage of it so
it's not like the video they're watching
had an encoding problem or their
internet is faltering that's what the
game actually looks like when you're
playing it the action just stops
seriously a full 2 seconds which I mean
after Reza doesn't sound like a lot but
when you're playing and just all of a
sudden everything freezes yeah it's
enough to be like what's going on and ok
there it goes it's it's weird man i'm
not a thumb all right why don't we see
the full review for homefront the
revolution on gamespot me up tomorrow
now that I've played all three versions
of the game which as I mentioned was not
the most fun i mean i don't i don't want
to completely crap all over the game it
does some cool things i had some fun
playing it it's it's a shame that it's
kind of a mess but yeah I mean I if yeah
I don't know let's see all right we've
got a score on it tomorrow yeah and then
yes we go go play on uncharted and doom
cuz they're they're pretty good but yeah
by all accounts doom doom is looking
pretty good and uncharted definitely so
far looking pretty awesome yeah we're
gonna talk about on just a second Scott
photo or thanks so much for come on Reed
appreciate it we're gonna swap you out
in a hot second for mr. Ben Howard it's
good let me at least let me say for more
than ones he might be wearing green
we'll see in a second oh man I hope so
pretty great come on in been we got a
lot of stuff to talk about we're not
gonna talk about doom and uncharted
quite yes first of all time boys I know
actually I'm not angry no it's quite a
group that's a great Danny yeah and
thanks for coming on is your first time
on a new set yeah it's very nice to be
here yeah I appreciate it admiring what
you guys have been doing in this
beautiful space yeah right we've a great
to have you in here we don't we don't
haven't got you in cuz we usually try
and get a lot of editorial people then
today they're all out or like Mary's at
a California extreme with was riding a
roller coaster yeah some nice effects
thing yeah I think they're doing so yeah
we'll have something on gamespot com
about that relatively soon alright we're
going to talk about uncharted and do
them in a bit but first of all I want to
talk to you gentlemen but modifications
mmm modifications for
games I don't know where this came from
I think there might have been a reddit
thread maybe during the week mods have
been on my mind since over watch because
I've been sort of thinking about all the
weird little directions first person
shooters went in and we talked about
battlefield on here last week and we
were talking about you know some of the
mods that came from there and had I fed
back into battlefield and I was just a
sort of had this idea of like just
having a talk about some of the mods
that have been the most influential and
in terms of the sort of lasting
impression they had on on video games
after the fact Ben what is like your
favorite module it's like the biggest
most impactful mod you think you played
well the one that sticks out for me or
the in terms of my memories I played the
most was day of defeat right was way
back in the half life one day yes like
99 yes there's no something um and I'm
really preceded a lot of the kind of
world war two first-person shooters it
was really before a lot of that stuff
came through quite a long time before
any of that stuff came through and
particularly the normandy beach landing
levels of though of that mod was
something that became at the office i
was working at the time like just a huge
deal i would status what we will play
every day you know played a little bit
of action quake and some rice things at
that time but encounter strike obviously
but that mod day of the fee was was was
the one and so yeah now that that one
for me would be will be a would be like
yeah half-life was a that engine seemed
to spawn mod after mile after Marge I
mean we had team fortress classic which
obviously you know goes back to quake
quake world team fortress before that
and but obviously that had a massive
sort of that whole class based online
shooter you know every one of them can
go back to that and we're seeing that an
overwatch a lot now whereas you know
it's it's essentially a classmate
shooter but instead of just five or six
different classes you've now got this
crazy 21 I mean people look at it and
look at MOBAs and they go oh it's that
hero thing would it's like a direct
evolution of what's happened there and
Peter what are some of the mods that you
sort of enjoyed playing growing up I
guess you were mostly a console gamer
growing up so saw the most part yeah I
mean like I played a bunch of pc games
but the one mod I will never forget is
the Randy Savage skyrock the most
impactful models immoral yeah no I mean
yes so for me
because I still in prime airily a
console gamer the way I look at Maude's
is sort of evidence of how great and
passionate the gaming community can be
and I may not play DotA right I may not
play counter-strike but I can really
appreciate the sort of the time and
energy that people put into this in the
enjoyment they get out of it mmm it
makes me wish that I had more time to be
involved in it to be honest with you so
to hear you guys like you know till you
talk about that was such passion it's
like that's a game that is only possible
because of the fans and here it is sort
of coming full circle it was it was
purely out people really wanted to play
a World War two yeah shooter right and
it was because it was around that time
the saving private ryan had come out
like people really nice experience that
wasn't that map particularly the
normandy beach landing map on their
defeat was you know it was an attempt it
was purely like what can we do to kind
of encapsulate what we're loving in the
movies at that time I think Skyrim is a
really good pic though because I I think
it says a popularizing mods I mean some
of the oblivion mods were were pretty
awesome actually some of the modding
that was going on there but really you
know Bethesda's foresight to really
include and encourage morning the way
they've done has completely changed the
landscape right i mean not just from
stupid mods like the chicken mods and
yeah and the and the Macho Man Randy
Savage mods are stupid but like level
creation knit the entire mapping of
morrowind right yeah all of this kind of
crazy stuff that comes from that
absolute passion I'm gonna be very
interesting to see how Skyrim or a
fallout Fallout you can do it on console
real soon in because a lot of that stuff
involves you know I mean anyone is
installed all of the skyrim mods knows
how much it chugs your pc even if you're
running Skyrim now on a very beefy pc
you start stacking those mods in there
it slows that thing down pretty quickly
so i don't know it's gonna be
interesting to see what they will they
do this yeah it's weird it's like this
strange little incubator for creativity
that you don't usually get in games cuz
games like take so long to develop like
their ideas do you don't see the end
result off for like two or three years
later but mods allow people to like just
like tweak with rules a little bit and
sort of make interesting you know like
you said like data feeds it wasn't the
most polished thing ever when i first
came out and then you look at things
like you know desert combat for
battlefield 1942 which was again when i
first
was pretty rough around the edges but
then that game ends up inspiring them to
go back and basically do battlefield 2
which was desert combat yeah well its
claims thinkers like game designers and
game developers modding is quite
antithetical to what they do right they
they have every right to be very
protective and proud of narration and
don't necessarily want us as fans
messing around with what they've created
and that's why I think someone like Todd
Howard's incredibly progressive nor be
no because he builds an open-world
sandbox but he also invites the
community to come in and change that
sandbox and do the most ridiculous
things with it you know a lot of game
creators it's it's not in their nature
to do that they're presenting to you
something that they've crafted and
created and so you know that sort of
shift from you know modding used to be
sort of black the dark side you know
right so people doing it sort of without
the knowledge you know and there were
particular on the pc would they were
just taking it into their own hands for
it to actually be encouraged and become
part of the game cycle is something
pretty incoming you know it's
progressive one of my favorite modding
stories comes from one of my favorite
game series I guess Unreal Tournament
2003 there was a mod that was made for
that where I think it was like one of
the background files there was like some
sort of textures for trucks and cars and
stuff and then the modding community got
a hold of it decided like building these
like car games within it and and then
some of those people including I think
David Hage would were brought into the
fold at epic and they were like all
right with these cars let's make a mode
out of it and that was unreal tournament
2004 onslaught mode and then he
eventually left epic started his own
company called psionics and then last
year we got rocket League which is
basically the like natural evolution of
that because all these weird football
mods came out for soccer mods came out
for foreign elements sort of in the
interim not something that happened over
the course of length 15 here using your
recent piece on over watch the video i
shot down a blizzard that those guys
talking about how a lot of the map
designers and those guys didn't come out
of designing necessarily at studios they
came out developing maps for the action
quake community and actually out of the
modding community a very much grass
roots level of devant of designing FPS
stuff yeah it's strange I like the sort
of seeds that get planted eventually so
a blossom years later am I've got I just
thought of something you guys walking so
before I missed my opportunity one of
the best games from last year was super
mario maker right yeah right but years
before Nintendo was doing that there was
a website called smw central net people
been hacking roms for a long time but
this website catered to a really hard
core audience of people who modified
super mario world and they created
editing engines multiple versions of
them like over the years to allow this
to happen and some of the games people
made are in my opinion may be better
than super mario world at certain points
so console gamers actually had that you
even had people then taking burning
eproms and putting them on circuit
boards making cartridges of their
favorite Super Mario mods but then you
see Christ follow suit and they'd
release phasing it would marry oh my god
the perfect example of how far modding
has come right intend oh yeah the most
protective company totally you can ever
imagine would build a game which is just
a modding tool for their biggest IP
their biggest license yeah it is isn't
is would have been impossible to think
of happening ten years ago I think you
know and we can't talk about mods and
the impact they've had in the industry
without talking about a certain Warcraft
3 mod though I mean like dota is
probably the the poster child for what
can happen if you if you mod something
and come up with a unique idea and it
sort of follow through to it to its end
point and I mean dota was like a popular
defensive the ancient was a popular mods
within certain communities for a long
time in the same way date if he probably
was where I had a very sort of core
passionate group of people that were
very very into it for a long long long
time before we saw the sort of explosion
with obviously league legends and then
eventually the I guess the rebirth of
dota through valve it's very easy to
forget that that's the origins of right
mode the modern mobile know that it
comes from a modding community and it
again it shows how far that stuff has
come that now we have things like a
legal legends and starcraft normal and
dr. too and we forget about the origins
of the mobile stuff but yeah it's crazy
and then sort of following on from some
of what we saw with with half-life
half-life 2 also had a large modding
community coming at Ash and natural
selection 2 came out which
was a I guess that was actually an
original half-life mod as well and they
sort of just made a new version of it
garry's mod that's gonna scary smart as
well of course Cody didn't even have it
on the list you of course doesn't he
make like a million dollars a day off
that day I don't know but yeah at some
point my in too much they don't like his
new game I have friends who the ortho oh
it's really a bit of a backlash about it
at the moment her friends of ours have
got teenage kids like 13 14 the things
they play they play Minecraft and they
play garry's mod to mental and if he
never played half life no no I can tell
you absolutely that the kids I spoke to
who I was chained to about Gary because
i was just fascinated by the fact that
they were playing gary's more than
that's all they wanted to talk about was
they'd never played half life one that
never played high 52 and yet garry's mod
is something which is like them post
play game so yeah it's it's really
strange though because like some of the
biggest like what half-life ones all
these massive multiplayer online sort of
connected world you know connective
online shooters came out of that but
they weren't half life two what we
actually saw was like the walking
simulator genre sort of burst out of it
like games like dear Esther and the
stanley parable and which sort of then
birth their own little sub-genre even
portal essentially right was wrong
skeleton of half-life 2 right yeah like
nerve ocular drop was a kind of a was a
digipen game and then yeah they sort of
find ok can you do that with this engine
do we have i mean i think they probably
wanted source 2 or whatever or that
version of source which is just a mean
source still to this day has pieces of
quake code in it and but like I think
they probably wanted out to be more of a
modding tool then it ended up sort of
becoming I'm oddly enough yeah I mean
they they they start they release that I
mean it was in the wake of Skyrim I like
portal to that they really tried to
encourage steam workshop in sapphire
never really caught fire remember at
that time we were doing the skyrim mod
show on games bill right over in the UK
and we were as steam workshop was
expanding well let what else can we roll
in and like Paul to felt like the
obvious next big thing in terms of
modding but it never seems very near
never really seemed to catch fire in the
same way it's weird how it's hard to
predict yeah totally is hard to predict
and I couldn't I was even surprised when
can or strike came back and I'm like a
huge counter-strike fans would like
when when source came out like even then
there was this bus massive backlash and
some people never came off 1.6 but csgo
I don't know what happened like they had
a new generation or something but that
just completely took off all over again
so it's really hard to sort of tell
especially these full conversion mods
and we're seeing less and less of them
and yeah so I guess having a look at
that and as loads we haven't talked
about I think about games like you know
Red Orchestra like science and industry
i remember in half-life 1 and there's so
many of these masks come out if we were
to say what was the most influential mod
that has ever been made though if you
were to pick well i think you probably
have to go with dawn of the Ancients
right just a defense that sort defensive
simply because we're what it's led to I
mean it I mean there's nothing there
there's nothing else which you in
completely create a completely new
gaming genre particularly one which has
taken over an industry and high industry
right so it's like I mean III see the
mobile industry and you know competitive
gaming now as a result sitting next to
what we traditionally cover and think of
as games i mean i don't think the two
audiences really cross over maybe as
often as we'd like yeah you know and
there's a lot of money to be made and a
lot of people who have a lot of jobs
yeah I know as a result of this like
it's intense you see like some of the
the venue's these guys fill like the
numbers they bring in all because some
guy had that idea one day like hey I'm
gonna screw with warcraft 3 yeah and
it's I'm consistently it's not even like
a we've seen would say starcraft or were
some other you know FPS is where they've
had their time in the sun and then
they've gone away again but DotA's been
around here for a good decent mountain
seems to continue building so yeah I'd
love to be able to say counter-strike
but probably is dota anyway we can go
play it out some other time and let us
know in the chat what you think is the
most influential mod of all time is a
dota is it something else is there a
weird mod that we didn't mention at all
either you'd like to get some eyes on
put it in the comments below all right
this next section I have ready is is how
do we talk about this game without
getting super super spoilery so what
I've written down a running order is
uncharted 4 is a great game dot dot dot
discuss okay
so I completed it last night no spoilers
here whatsoever not gonna get is that
yeah you guys are like getting into it
how many chapters except my plate it say
ok so I'm ten chapters in ok probably
halfway ok yeah ran halfway I'm 11
chapters in ok you're also probably
halfway yes and what are your initial
sort of feelings on it at Peter Mike my
hearty obviously reviewed for us 10 and
10 on gamespot com and you fan of the
series already coming into this what do
you think about nope nope I played the
original in charity for about two hours
and thought man this game plays like ass
but did you play two or three no okay
never had a chance um there were a lot
better than one that's what I've heard
but now I kind of want to go back
honestly um if they're anything like
uncharted 4 which for me what what
really struck me was the pacing is
really really good and the sort of
different beats that it hits they they
really inspire a sense of awe in so many
ways like whether it is a small
interaction between two characters and
that could be either someone reacting
anyway you don't usually see or a
character being oddly flawed when you
sort of look at them as someone who is
supposed to be like the the impeccable
hero right but then it's the the
incredible landscapes and the vistas and
and the action moments that sort of
appear not really out of the blue but in
such a way that just feels like wow
where did this come from I'm in the
middle of it right now and then I'm
swinging from a rope over an ocean with
like storms brewing and it's like it's a
very magical experience it's not
something that I look to as a is a
mechanically challenging or risky game
right but that's okay i don't think
every game has to be that and for what
uncharted does i can't say i've played a
game that does that aspect as well in
terms of the pacing and the attention to
detail we think about it's obviously a
phenomenal game and I think what what
it's so special about on child for I
love the previous uncharted games they
get a lot better after the first one the
first one you know it it was an
extension of that post tomb raider
Indiana Jones you know tomb raiding
dungeon
delving you know pushing buttons on
statues and making stuff happen as its
progressed they've introduced more of a
story to him but it's still very been
very much been certainly in two and
three straight up action set-pieces i
think the real triumph of four is to
meld together what they do so well with
action which is i mean i think that the
best in the business in terms of
straight up action set-pieces on in the
console generation combined with real
emotional weight and they do some stuff
not talk specifically about the story
but there is stuff very early on that's
introduced which gives drake's actions
that gives the characters that the the
tomb raiding you want to call it that
the the treasure-hunting stuff real
weight and real emotional purpose and
that's obviously stuff they've learned
from doing their child games but also
doing you know the last of us and you
know that that stuff i think has really
shown how much that stuff has bled
through you know there's obviously you
can easily go they've introduced and
stealth stop more stealth stuff from
last of us but i think the real thing
that they've they bought over from those
games is the emotional way that those
games have yeah and so in between the
great action set-pieces there is real
drama that you actually care about and
it's the first time in the series i
would say that there has been real drama
that has real consequences and really
matters for the characters and that that
is what it contributes to it being such
a really great package yeah i've totally
agreed so the story stuff that they talk
about it as well as is very sort of like
it's not grandiose it's not the end of
the world stuff it's just simple human
problems and it's ridiculous to the game
which involves you murdering hundreds of
people has this like you know beautiful
little core tourist it's like a motion
of the story happening in the middle of
it and and that's what made me like for
a game like peter said for a game that
like mechanically isn't like reinventing
the wheel by any means it's a competent
shooter and and i actually like the
traversal and i think it's a bit more
simple than something like Tomb Raider
and actually like it first and but for a
game that there has that sort of doesn't
have that moment to moment amazing you
know core gameplay I was I thought
propels to keep playing it all the time
because the story stuff is so good and I
don't know I think after years of
playing games you kind of
get a little bit burnt out on new
environments maybe they don't hit as
hard as it was but there's something
about this game it's gorgeous first of
all but just the design and it this way
stuff looks it's just I want to see more
of it it was like I was on holidays and
I wanted to go for a walk to enjoy it
but also i mean the previous games have
always had variety of location I mean it
just in the first three hours of playing
this game I think you visited like four
countries yeah you know three different
environments and it you know it it's
amazing what it keeps throwing at you in
it will you tell us if it if it keeps
throwing that at your way through but
certainly where I'm at you know however
far into the game I feel like it's
always throwing something new at me you
know which obviously great game design
should do it should always you know you
shouldn't be posting too long you should
always be introducing new mechanics and
new stuff and yeah I mean it's you know
there are also masters of getting the
most out of current console
disconnection cramming is that I can't
believe I can't think of anything else
that looks as good as this or has looked
as good as this on any console
generation comparatively you know it's
like it really is just mind-blowing how
could this game looks perfect I mean it
was funny we were talking last week
about how you know you can't talk about
any good-looking video game and it's
somebody mentioning the 30 60 thing this
game exists like perfectly in 30 frames
a second it's a cinematic experience and
it was never a moment where I thought oh
I wish this was like more fluid it and
it looks unbuttoning this console is all
right like if they if somebody can get
this out of the console then like we're
not doing too bad between this and doom
it's almost like restore my most or my
faith in the current generation of
consoles its detail they throw in like
leaves just dropping from the trees or
dust being thrown up and being caught by
the sunlight you know wait till you see
the mud Oh with the car tracks it's like
oh my god well I remember the car chase
demo from e3 right sharing that set
piece I mean I was Santa theater
watching that with with Randy and like
it finished and I just went that's the
greatest action set piece I've ever seen
in a being demoed to me it like 83 is
incredible like them yeah and yet they
had the time to throw in all these
ridiculous select modes like things you
can turn on after the fact right yeah
like play the game you know in a
kaleidoscope world or what
I don't know what they are but it's just
incredible to me like we're all for the
links they go that most studios never
have the time or money to go mm-hmm they
still found ways to go above and beyond
those expectations we have from a studio
like naughty dog yeah it's incredible
it's great game you played the
multiplayer I have not even touched it
yeah I suspect that's the case for a lot
of people I mean on to uncharted threes
multiplayer was it was better than i was
expecting i enjoyed it i think a lot of
playstation we talked about it a bit
last week about like seven playstation
fans were sort of that was a really good
scoop for them because like a lot of
xbox people think is war and I was fun
you know this is a game that was worth
the asking price regardless of its
multiples even there so I'm sure I'll
jump into it at some stage but kind of
like doom actually I'm fine with this as
it is and it's in turn I'll replay it
I'll happily we play uncharted and I
would never play a third person replay a
third person action game but this is the
whole yeah I'm already wanting to go
back and replay stuff that I've played
up to this point hmm it's certainly the
best console exclusive I can remember in
a very long time yeah times of you know
console wars and what we talked about
things making the difference to it being
a system seller yeah i mean this this is
it right if Sony needed to sell more
systems this would do it already in a
pretty good situation uh yeah see you
guys excited to jump back in are you
interested in playing the multiplayer at
all are you just happy to get the
campaign over and done with I mean I'm a
dip in and try it by I mean I there's so
many other multiplayer games i'm
interested in playing right now or about
to come out tick-tock overwatch yeah
right so i mean there are you know and
i'd like to dig into doom a little bit
and play some of that i'm actually
really enjoying battleborn still so I
mean it's not like there's a shortage of
multiplayer stuff to do right now so
yeah it's I think it's gonna be a single
player experience for me yeah seem cool
no interest yeah all right there you go
I'm trying to for a spoiler-free little
chinwag about that one Michael be sad he
wasn't here for this chin while I was
gonna say poor guy that's things you
lose you can read his review and his got
his thoughts on uncharted 4 at gamespot
com it got a 10 and a 10 and I think all
three of us at the table would agree
that that is very very it was very very
worth it okay let's have a little chat
about doom in a second but first of all
I'm like waiting to get myself all like
amped up and energize cuz like I can't
talk about doing without demoting like
crazy [ __ ] your shotgun on the on the
on the beat of music we're playing Judas
Priest in my head psyching myself up and
before we talk about dooms specifically
last week you know we got copies of doom
like barely before I guess we didn't
even get them before it came out we came
out on release day we actually got
copies on release day right we got in a
few hours early because Australia
technically got it on release day which
is in the few past feature it depends
are you looking at it I guess and but it
sort of turned up this whole discussion
again about you know Oh red flag start
wave get start to get waved whenever
again comes out and big publisher
decides to hold back review copies and
there's a bunch people tweet about it
over the weekend we were having a big
chat about kevin van award was to embed
it seemed like in his his professional
experience this there was no ever never
really any correlation between it and
Peter what do you think you've been
reviewing games for a long long time
you've had early access to games you've
probably been in a couple of review
events I'm guessing as well and you've
had games not turn up and had to review
them as quickly as you can is there any
sort of correlation between that do you
ever sort of see red flags waving
whenever publishers decide to not give
us all ready access to stuff it
certainly makes you wonder but I would
be lying if I said that there is a like
definite correlation that I've noticed
right you know I mean sure yeah there
are times when games are not good and a
publisher knows that because I don't
know if anyone else out there knows that
but they hire people to review games
before they send out copies for reviews
known as internal mock reviews and a
large part of mock reviews is is to sort
of allocate things like marketing
budgets and stuff like that isn't it
sure yeah yeah you know to understand
like okay what are we going to face how
do we plan accordingly to match that so
yeah I'm certain they're instances when
the game did not show up on time because
they knew it was going to be a poor
experience I think they just gonna be a
Friday the 13th joke I really don't know
why we didn't get doomed all right
before the release day um but I'm not
that bothered like as someone whose job
it is to review the game yeah it's like
a pain in my butt but I don't really
care because doom ended up being it's
really really good
and I don't I don't know why they would
have been nervous about it may be
because the multiplayer isn't so hot
snap map I'm the multiplayer maybe
they've maybe they were worried about
people putting as reviews without having
experienced that stuff at a time yeah I
don't know but like but it's just as
well yeah you know like there's there's
stuff you can do and fall out that kind
of falls into that camp but not
multiplayer but you know like just weird
stuff and we got that put plenty of time
all right um but yeah I know in my
experience I think it's you know it's a
case-by-case basis there's not like some
conspiracy you know especially between
publishers and outlets like you know we
kind of just roll with whatever they're
willing to give us and in this case oh
well we didn't get it early let's talk
about a couple of instances that have
happened because you said it is on a
case-by-case basis I mean almost the
opposite of what's happening with doom
is what's happened with homefront is
that we actually did get that relatively
early we've done learning some stage
last week yeah we got a Wednesday right
believe yeah yeah which I could have
been a game that could they could have
held off i mean the reviews aren't super
hot at the moment right and that window
of time is pretty typical for a lot of
games even some really big games which
you know kind of sucks but yeah i mean
who knows why they didn't hold that back
right you wonder if they want people to
buy the game on launch day to not be
scared off by poor reviews then it might
hold it back and i think that's why
people some people think that's the case
but it's evidence of the fact that
that's maybe not the case all the time
when we see a game like old friendship I
think a lot of the reason people have
that expectation is because of what
happens with film criticism and film
releases right so quite often with film
releases if if and this is much more due
to quality if the quality and they are
anticipating bad reviews they will not
screen it to the press now normally
national press screenings for movies
happen you know the Monday all the
tuesday before the friday release date
okay enough time for that week's
national newspapers and stuff to
circulate out quite often they if a
movie skips that that press schedule
then the critics will have to go see it
on friday finding morning with the
public right they miss and that's
because for film you know the friday and
saturday or the opening weekend box
office is there is the most critical
period if you can protect at least your
friday and saturday night then then
which is obviously not the case of games
which have a much bigger obviously
really the first few weeks of release
are very important but you know for
for film studios is much more about
protecting that Friday nights and I box
office and so if they're worried that
films gonna receive negative criticism
they'll often not show it to the press
so that they can least get a good friday
night maybe even a Saturday night before
the bad word starts to spread around it
but as as pizzas I mean it's it's it's
really not the case and we see so many
different examples from you know I mean
you know a few years ago Ubisoft with
with unity where the Rio embargo was hot
six hours after the game had actually
been released right you know and
obviously that game had some technical
issues two two two examples like doom
where you know again I'm no idea why
well I mean I think I don't even know if
they said to us it was due to the online
components but obviously I mean that's a
that is an element and when you do get
out games that have a large online
component to them that is often the case
where where they'll want to try them in
the wild which is obviously how we
review games anyway we won't put a game
out and there's a large online component
until we've tested it in public
environment anyway so yeah it seems like
it can happen not as often as the film
world but it can happen but it's all it
almost seems like the inverse of that
happens as often then that we just get
late copies it's not as easy as you can
say oh yeah no early reviews out of the
games terrible yeah you know it doesn't
work like a lot of people you know did
not like the new starfox right I can you
showed up weeks yeah what about on
charters was the embargo for the US I
think we had just about over a week with
the game maybe a little bit less yeah
yeah it's funny how it works out I I
wondered with doom as well was it
something to do with the fact that they
were releasing on a friday which is
typical for the European market but
obviously not the case over here well
they can send us digital codes right and
so we're not necessarily dealing with
like market distribution well I was I
was thinking maybe they needed some like
distance from uncharted or something but
they're landing in a sort of weird me to
my situation yeah that's not possible it
could have been totally logistical too
yeah you know and we would just never
know yeah maybe they just couldn't get
them out on time it's weird how this
stuff works anyway thanks for chatting
about it because it is the same thing
and especially like before I was sort of
involved in the price I always want I
think people wonder about this stuff a
lot of the time and they wonder we know
what gears are sort of working in the
background and
the reality I think when you come in and
see it is that actually there are so
many gears working it's not like there
is some sort of i don't know like quid
pro quo thing happening it's just that
sometimes people work within the limits
and sometimes things fall out of the
norm and there's not necessarily any
like correlation between two children at
the time even the person I'm talking to
you about the game doesn't have any
power or idea when they are getting the
code right yeah and if I was definitely
the case in the UK as well actually when
we were getting games which were coming
from external was yeah people like
third-party pea or companies I same
stuff all right thank you both so much
now let's talk about doom lovely doom
doom is actually I have no right status
you what you are in the process of
reviewing the game there's a review in
progress up on gamespot through people
be out later today it's that we are
putting the finishing touches on all the
components that comprise the game's fire
can you tell us the school right now
would you fire me no I think I mean I
think you could probably tell where
where you're landing only your you like
it I'm very positive on the game ok yeah
no ray yeah it uh I didn't know how I
felt about doom going into it the e3
presentation that focused so much on
maury kills to me was a huge red flag
and so going into this review I that was
sort of the biggest question I needed
answered and almost immediately I
realize that like no these are fine and
everything around it is way more awesome
than I expected because I thought maybe
the focus was in the wrong place right
yeah but it's not and it's doom is is
just a crazy over-the-top just
overwhelming think experience like it's
nuts everything's on fire everything is
screaming everything is exploding
there's blood everywhere and that's and
that sounds like maybe a really cheap
way to make a game exciting but like the
way that it's paste and delivered to you
is just so well and with such an
attitude and unapologetic attitude about
what it is and where it comes from yeah
and I I was just super happy to realize
that this I remember playing doom as a
kid I feel the same way today I did back
then is not bizarre and you're not the
only person that said that I completely
agree I know Brad a giant bomb had the
same
things band same for you as I yeah I
mean for me I mean it it's excess is
beautiful like everything from
everything p says so the the metal
guitar salmon is that we've said this a
lot but it's the most metal game this
happen it really makes you want to raise
devil horns just come bang your head but
but it there's also like a beauty
despite all this access it's also got
this beautiful simplicity to it which
really encapsulate what is that made you
fall in love with doom in the first
place um we were talking about this the
other day you know dhoom3 I like doing
through a great deal but never felt like
do to me yeah yeah it was almost like a
survival horror right yeah this
perfectly translates what it was or what
my memories and feelings are from
playing those many many hours of doom
and doom 2 2 to the 21st century you
know it totally captures quite a night
it's almost reductive I think to say old
school all right fashioned because I I
think that would imply some kind of
retro experience and it doesn't feel
like a retro experience it it does
encapsulate what it those feelings you
have from playing classic doom but it
doesn't do it in a way that feels
nostalgic or retro again it does it in a
in a very sort of modern package yeah
it's got it looks great it sounds
incredible and it has a lot of things
peppered into it little systems right
that are like modern touches things that
we find in modern games that weren't
present in doom that I think make it an
experience that we can look but not not
just referred to as retro like it feels
modern but it delivers that same thing
that made that experience back bends so
great which really kicked off a genre
you know I mean shooters weren't really
that big of a thing before doom yeah I
mean we talked about Wolfenstein as
obviously one of the first ones not be
first but but Doom was the one that like
really just went out and caught on yeah
people look stood up and listened that's
what's weird about doom is that if you
were to ask me like two weeks ago what
was a doom game on what I would want in
a dune game I would like talk about
stuff like I don't know atmosphere and
like interesting enemies and interesting
weapons which were kind of all things
that were covered in dhoom 3 much for
muchness and but the weird thing about
this doom is that i was playing this and
I was realizing the things about the
original games that I actually did like
that
in this I totally forgotten about things
like like the effect of wandering around
and being lost and looking at that weird
map and trying to find where the secrets
are which is like how they made that fun
of the 2016 games like beyond me and
like even looking for a yellow keys and
red keys I mean that became a joke about
a bad level design for years and years
about how to artificially yeah they and
they put it out there and they do here
and they do it but they do joy that it
never feels boring to me the only stuff
that didn't work for me is there's
obviously one of the big things they
introduced here is verticality yes a lot
of mantling and jumping up ledges in
there there are some sections which sort
of resort to sudo platforming stump
where you have to sort of negotiate your
way up a little maze of of shelves yeah
and it that staff didn't doesn't quite
work I mean I think the mantling super
fun when you're doing it in combat
because the verticality in combat is
great so you got demons coming from
above and below you in some cases but
the straight up platforming stuff is the
only thing I didn't really enjoy the
game and got a little bit takes expand
on that alas you sad end up doing like
sideStrafe jumping and stuff based on
yeah especially if you going to like the
rune challenges I I don't know if you go
near the the time-based platforming ones
yet not yet Oh jump maps they're back
like even dancer stuff like I totally
forgot that and do one into like red
barrel placement was like in totally
amends for like trying to clear out
rooms and they're everywhere and they're
everywhere in fact the point where you
have to stay the hell away from them
because you'll just get insta kills
liner basically from but that whole
thing about like exploding do you rember
that like you can see the animation your
head when there's like a pinky or an imp
coming towards you and you set off the
thing the red barrel and it explodes and
you see them move slightly to the side I
just burst into blood yeah very good
impression be like it's got that feeling
to it where you like you're just
detonating death all over the place and
it's yeah like I for a game that has
gone from pillar to post and had such a
long and weird development history it's
so strange that this game has such a
strong identity yeah like it knows what
it's so pure it's so straightforward and
it doesn't mask the fact that you are
basically walking from arena to arena
right you enter a room they say oh
there's demons we got to lock it down
until you kill them all
you do that you move on and it's just
like you just want the next one to
happen like that that's really all it is
but the way that they you know a lot of
the maps are designed are intricate
enough and challenging enough like pack
of demons that really push you to Lin it
and you're constantly scrambling for
your resources like it's that's it's
that tension that anxiety like I'm
white-knuckled wide-eyed staring at my
TV like tiger for like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you know like again ah yeah the way it
it's not it has such confidence in its
combat to make the combat the star and
it doesn't try yeah it doesn't have a
loads of cutscenes and they could have
done a real Wolfenstein I'll i love
Wolfenstein but they could have put on a
lot of more campaign and story and
characters but they really that they're
not afraid just to make it about the
combat you know and that the glory kills
and the chainsaw or the cherry on top
cause its way that changes the gameplay
and turns it into a beautiful rhythmic
thing where where those things you know
the executions and the chain stores
which i think when we all saw that demo
back at e3 yeah the glory kills it's
like that's hope that just feels like it
slows it all down I haven't seen a game
mechanic ii have such a like 180
reaction in my life was like it looked
like oh god they're putting contextual
kills in Dhoom 2 oh this is actually
dislike solved the medi-pack hunt
problem that would not work in 2016 and
but a place so well liked and beyond
just trying to get that health right
like so I'm facing down an enemy I'm
losing health mmm I have like no ammo
I'm loading everything I have it in like
please stagger please stagger please
stagger they stagger and I sprint in to
tear them open and I'm like I'm back
it's just like let's go I chase'll is
the same thing right yes super limited
on fuel yeah and you'll save that fuel
until you see a big enemy is gonna take
a lot of your fuel drag down on the
insta kill but you know it's gonna top
up all your ammo yeah so like that
there's all this undermining underlying
strategy going on in your brain which
didn't exist before the chainsaw was
just a fun weapon to slice be open with
right it's like a joke or much yeah so
all of those things they've made
actually meaningful and part of what
you're doing again it sort of you know
making it all about the combat you know
and that it takes it back to that feel
like you're alone you're you know
they're there is little bits of story
elements there if you want to find them
and they're you know there are also some
additional secret stuff which unlocks
you know like a an appendices kind of
thing
yeah but I actually quite like I think
those are ribs good job in that right
well I mean you don't need to look no
right your way it tells its story though
is really like quite what the fact you
break out of like a stone sarcophagus
yeah and then like your bloody do marble
centigram on the right and like the hell
talks about you is the dude the dooms
Slayer like yeah it's like the idea of
like deifying this ridiculous character
who didn't really even her name in the
original games yeah um let's talk about
I guess some of the other maybe
shortcomings it might have like have you
doubled with some of the other modes
actually like multiplayer stuffs not my
phone yeah before we get to that I mean
I will say like the campaign delivers so
many great things but it does lack a lot
of variety you're right um there cuz you
know its doom you go to hell sorry I
blew it yeah you gotta Helen you go to
Mars and you go back forth to hell to
Mars to held a Marcel de Mars and that
gets pretty wrote right that bothered me
but the game does find its footing again
later on in the campaign so that was
fine now resolved itself the multiplayer
stuff is is very very basic it captures
sort of part of the combat that makes
dune so special but it doesn't give you
the the odds the sort of like the
crushing looming odds in your face when
you enter an arena in the campaign I
feel like I'm playing halo right yeah
just with a little bit of satanic
dressing yeah time yeah it feels like a
game you've played already yeah like
it's fine yeah but it's it's it's not
the sort of thing where I'm gonna talk
about it with anyone I'm not gonna bring
that up that's not the topic of
discussion and what about this not my up
stuff uh they actually so I think that's
pretty cool the tutorials are pretty
straightforward they teach you how to do
everything within a matter of minutes I
was able to just move stuff around and
place it take it out put it back in undo
things there's a lot of room there to be
creative they let you do things like you
know Taylor the text that appears on
screen in different parts of the
environment and different parts of
omission you can use logic and
interesting ways to have different
objects activate things and some of the
stuff that the communities don't is is
pretty good for a game that's only been
out a handful of days it seems to me the
thing that the community will really run
with down the road and for a game that
has at its core the ability to deliver
something that the campaign does I'm
hoping the community can also build upon
that Yeah right I mean talk about mods
lie
dhoom can have those within the game and
I cannot wait to see you already saw
some pretty dumb stuff when you like
that yeah there's the fake piano yeah
there's like a big there's like a music
room there was a moment like a drum
sequencer or something yeah that was
yeah I had a cowbell in the corner I
mean you can every detail how much that
stuff's been made by eight ahead of time
right i guess but uh yeah you'd hope so
i'm like i imagine i'm not sure if i
asked marty this when he was in two
weeks ago but i imagine you could do
some sort of cross-platform selcas snap
map is just a tool right so if somebody
made something on PlayStation 4 what is
dr. they talk about ac3 can you can you
do to cross platform maybe I'm mixing it
up with this basically one snapchat I
mean when you login to snapchat just
close the game and reboot into snatcher
yeah just for multiplayer map snap oh
yeah snap job yeah they've included
snapchat I didn't do here's a here's the
funky town level I play as well they're
funky town is playing on this disco so
yeah great that's just the right 11 it's
the right level of dumb yeah right there
and yeah it's I guess well you know
Peters point is totally right we'll see
it's but lives or dies on what the
community does right so we'll have to
wait and see because hopefully if it's
cross-platform than the pool of
creations then is shared that will be
you know hopefully everyone gets to
enjoy the spoils of the the good stuff
that's made ya do ones review up later
today cool I mean yeah we're literally
just polishing it right it's really not
you'll say just lighting the last
candles and placing the last bloody
skulls than the review alright so yeah
check back on gamespot com to see Peters
review for doom and that's it that's a
show no Ben thank you come on not
pleasure thank [ __ ] what's on why do you
pay for the rest your week uh well I'm
gonna finish uncharted and then I'm
gonna play more more doom and all and I
also i keep saying all and go back and
play some more battle born because I
actually do like battle born yo mam but
with the overwatch beta and
righteousness I kind of got distracted
from it by yeah I'm gonna go back and
try and play a little more of that so
yeah video games not enough time I got
two kids Danny I have a fair play this
month especially has been
than really warm like solid games all
over this place Peter what are you gonna
be playing yourself finishing uncharted
and then die diving into far harbor oh
cool of course yeah I actually gotta go
forth over the weekend I'm much to the
chagrin of Randy probably I really clean
did not play any that's all I need to do
that this week I'm so Sonny's not here
to hear that okay good good and yeah and
then we're only a week away from
overwatch I guess 24th is it they
release them I must be no Tuesday
today's a 17 so who knows anymore
Tuesday's who knows Doom is just like
blown open possibilities on reviews and
thank you so much to everyone who
watched today on gas bottle and on
twitch of course thank you for listening
on your podcast software of choice make
sure to rate and subscribe and do all
that fun stuff will be back here next
Tuesday 2 p.m. pacific until then check
out gamespot.com for all the latest news
reviews and whatnot have a great week of
playing video games and we'll see you
next time adios